When it comes to
performance, there
is one technique that
governs all of computing.
Without it, your
computer basically
would not exist or work at all.
I'm Joanna Smith, and caching
is as fundamental to performance
as it is to the design of
the hardware in the phone
that you're holding.
If you think about it,
there's a pretty clear reason
why computers have RAM.
It acts as a data cache to
access recent information
fast-- like super fast--
compared to having
to get it from the hard drive.
And this is basically
what a cache is-- a place
to store data that's frequently
used so that future uses happen
as fast as possible.
Anytime that you have an
overhead cost for computing
a piece of data, or
loading it, or finding it,
a cache can help you do it
faster and more effectively
the second time,
and the third time,
and the-- you get the idea.
So, in your app, the
most common place
where you can win
with caching is
when you have data that is
calculated multiple times,
but the result is
always the same.
No one would ever argue
to move nonvariable work
into an inner loop, but it
may surprise you how easy
it is to do this by mistake.
Consider a simple
example where you're
calculating the derivative
of a four-by-four matrix
to use when calculating
your loop control variable.
But that matrix never
changes within the loop,
so you're actually
wasting performance
recomputing the derivative
on each iteration.
Instead, compute and save the
result outside of the loop
and let the inner portions
of your loop reference
that cached result.
This may sound obvious
when presented like this,
but you would be surprised how
even seasoned developers get
caught by it.
Like when calling
Get Current User
inside of a loop in a
single user environment,
like a mobile game.
Caching also acts as
a fantastic resource
for our limited
resource environments.
For example, let's say that
you have about 2 gigabytes
of images that the user
might need to display,
but you can only fit
50 megabytes of them
in memory at a time.
So the Android framework will
help you out as much as it can,
if you use an adapter view.
But you can make this
more effective by keeping
track of what images
to keep in memory
and which to evict so
that the framework doesn't
need to evaluate the full
2 gigabytes of content.
Then there's the
less common form
of caching known
as pre-computation.
This is essentially where you
spend time offline to calculate
a huge lookup table or
a massive XML schema
so that at runtime you can
simply fetch that data rather
than executing all
that expensive overhead
while your user is waiting.
And that's the whole point--
avoiding unnecessary work.
So if you're looking to make
performance improvements
or trying to build a new app
that's already Perf perfect,
take a pass through
places where you loop,
or load data, or have heavy
computation, and see what
you can shift around.
Also, avoiding unnecessary
work is pretty much all we talk
about in the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns content
and in our G+ community, which
is why you should check both
of them out.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
Perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]